- Hi guys, this is Heinrich
from Firm Learning,
and thank you very much
for watching my channel.
So yesterday I was sitting at the airport
in Düsseldorf waiting for my plane,
because there was a delay
due to some bad weather
in Munich, apparently.
So I was reading so many of the messages
that I received from you in the last days,
and several of you
actually asked me "Well,
"thank you for your videos on blockchain,
"but what is the actual relevance of that?
"How can businesses
benefit from blockchain?
"How is that relevant
to my day-to-day life
"to the business I'm working for,
"as a business professional
in my 30 years of my career?"
So in this video I'm
giving you an overview
of all of the use cases for businesses
that blockchains have.
And I specifically deep dive
into one type of use cases,
focused around assets,
around digital assets
and digital collectibles.
This video is part of my online
video series on blockchain
where I'd like to teach you
both technology fundamentals
but also business
implications and use cases
of this new technology.
These videos are part of
a larger online course
that I created around
exactly these topics.
So if you're really serious about learning
to speak blockchain, to
understand what it's all about,
and how businesses can actually leverage
this new technology, have
a look at my online course.
I have over 8000 students
taking the course,
there is the link below
in the video description
where you'll find a link,
have a look at that if
this might interest you.
Now let's directly jump
into the video on use cases.
In this section we will
focus on use cases.
We will discuss different
kinds of applications
and things you can actually do and build
with blockchains, and explain
how this will be useful
for the industry, for people
and for businesses in general.
Of course, blockchains need to enable
tangible use cases to be successful.
Blockchain is an exciting
and interesting technology,
but if it would turn out
that we cannot really
do something with that,
this technology will remain unimportant.
And not be used, and not
be relevant in the future.
So what can we actually
do with blockchains?
In the book "The Business Blockchain"
William Mougayar introduces a framework
which I find very interesting and useful
in order to discuss this topic.
It is the ATOMIC framework.
And ATOMIC can be used as a mnemonic
in order to help you memorize
some key blockchain use
case areas that we will now
explore in more detail
in the later lectures.
So the first letter of
ATOMIC A stands for assets.
So blockchain can help us
secure assets on a blockchain.
T stands for trust, blockchain
is a trustless technology,
it doesn't require that the users
of blockchains trust each other.
O stands for ownership.
It can facilitate proof of
ownership, proof of identity,
and there are use cases that
really revolve around that.
M for money.
Of course cryptocurrencies
are the most prevalent
use case of blockchain, we are
most familiar with that one.
I for identity.
Proof of identity is important as well.
With blockchains you
can legitimate yourself
as the person that you actually are.
And C, contracts.
Smart contracts are a
huge topic for itself,
probably you could make whole courses
about the topic as well,
we will discuss that as
well in the later lectures
how this plays along.
One important note that I wanna make
is that, of course, many use cases
will touch different ones of these areas.
So a use case can be all about
assets and money as well.
And probably bitcoin
would be a good example.
Bitcoin is a way of payment,
you can use it as money,
but it's also considered an asset.
And, of course, it's
also kind of trustless,
because the uses of the bitcoin network,
you don't need to trust each other.
So hope you understand that many use cases
touch different aspects
of this ATOMIC framework.
Nevertheless, I think this is
a useful way to conceptualize
the different advantages and use cases
that blockchain can bring to the table.
In this lecture we will cover
the first group of use cases,
and this is the group of
use cases related to assets.
For assets, blockchains
provide a whole set
of distinctive advantages
compared to prior use cases
and solutions that existed.
With the help of a blockchain
digital assets can be created
and safely stored on the blockchain.
The assets can also be
moved among different users
of the blockchain in order
to facilitate the transfer
or the change of ownership of an asset.
In addition, prior intermediaries
can be disintermediated.
Maybe in the past there was a bank,
or some kind of other
clearance institution
that helped you to create
and move these assets.
These intermediaries are
no longer required anymore.
And this will help you with
transaction times as well.
To make a bank transaction for instance,
in the future a bank
usually took several days
in order to be able to
clear the transactions.
On a blockchain this happens
virtually immediately
because the blockchain will not require
any kind of intermediaries like that.
From this analysis, a whole
set of use cases arises.
And here are a few examples,
this is not necessarily
an exhaustive list,
but I hope this gives
you a first understanding
of what is possible.
The first group of examples
is a group of examples
related to Colored Coins.
And Colored Coins are
representation of real world assets
in the digital sphere that
facilitate the handling
and trade of these assets.
So imagine you have a car,
to make a simple example,
you have bought a car, you own a car,
and now you want to secure your ownership
of the car in the blockchain.
And maybe in the future transfer
the ownership of the car
without a need to go through
some kind of intermediary,
to some kind of legal scholar to help you
facilitate and set up all the paperwork.
Now you could use a blockchain
in order to create a record
of you owning this car, in the blockchain,
that kind of contains
all of the information
that is required.
And this record of the asset
that you actually possess
is called a Colored Coin.
So kind of a digital coin that is colored
with all of the information
of the actual physical asset.
And now in the future, if you
would like to trade the car,
instead of meeting somebody
and giving them the car
you could just reassign the coin
that represents your car on the blockchain
to another person as a sign
of transfer of ownership.
So this is the whole
concept of Colored Coins.
Somehow related to that is the concept
of digital collectibles,
so you could create
collectibles on blockchain.
And due to the blockchain
these collectibles
will be protected, that you own them,
this would be clear from the blockchain.
And also the rarity and
other relevant properties
of the collectible will be protected,
because there's no central institution
that can just release more
items of the collectible.
So think of collectible cars,
or maybe collectible coins,
or any kind of other collectible assets
that right now, today,
exist in the physical world.
You're often at risk that
the central institution
that gives out these
collectibles just recreates them,
reprints them, and increases the quantity
of these collectibles.
And this is not possible if you use
collectibles on a blockchain
and the blockchain is
set up in the right way.
And then online gaming,
the same is true there.
Imagine you're playing in online game
where you maybe even spent the money
in order to advance your character,
or you have bought certain items that help
your character progress in the game,
now you're always at risk
that the central institution
that leads the game, the game publisher,
or the game creator, suddenly
changes the rule of the game,
and now the item that
you bought in the past,
for hard money, isn't worth it anymore
because the properties of
the items have changed,
for instance.
And actually there's a fun
story of Vitalik Buterin,
the founder of Ethereum,
actually once having
been said that he said
that he was playing World of Warcraft,
the big and famous online game,
and he had some kind of character.
And suddenly, Blizzard, the
creator of World of Warcraft
changed the rule, and now the character
wasn't as effective as it was before.
And he spent literally
lots and lots of hours
into his character, in
order to make the character
as strong as it was, and he
really got angry about that.
Which Vitalik says was one of the reasons
why he now created Ethereum.
So I do not know if this
is actually true or not,
but I hope this provides a good example
of what is possible with storage
of assets on blockchains.
In order to provide a few examples
of projects that exist out
there that actually do that,
one project is called Coins,
it is a storage service,
stores asset metadata
to the Bitcoin blockchain,
and focuses on banking applications.
And that's exactly what I
just talked about earlier,
it's a way of implementing and using
the Colored Coin use case
that I just described.
A second example in the
online gaming sphere
is Deckbound, it is a gaming platform
that you can create
strategic digital card games.
And these cards that you're creating,
they're stored to your account,
and the value of these cards is preserved.
And this way it makes sure that
there's no central institution
suddenly diminishing
the value of your cards.
And finally, probably
the most famous example
on this page is CryptoKitties.
It was the first big
use case implementation
of the digital collectible use case
on the Ethereum blockchain.
And the idea is that basically
by playing CryptoKitties
you can create these cats,
and these cats are stored on a blockchain,
and these cats have different value,
depending on what
property these cats have.
And then these cats can be traded
and exchanged with other people.
So a form of a digital collectible.
And in fact the CryptoKitties
was an extremely successful
example of such a use case.
So this is a TechCrunch article
that was just written a few days
after the CryptoKitties use
case, or service, was launched.
And it reports that within a few days
over one million US dollars
has been transacted.
So kitties worth over
one million US dollars
have been bought, and they're
individual transactions
ranging from over $20,000 to over $100,000
that were spent on individual Kitties.
So of course, it's probably questionable
how sustainable that is, but this provides
a first understanding of
what might be possible,
and how relevant the use
case for digital collectibles
might become in the future.
So, thank you for watching,
I hope you found this insightful,
and now this helps you to
understand how businesses
can actually make use of the
new blockchain technology.
This was now a deep dive on
the asset type of use cases,
but as I said in the beginning,
there are other interesting
use cases as well.
If you would like to learn more about that
check out my full online course
on blockchain technology,
there's a link in the
video description below.
And if this video was
at all helpful to you,
please press the like button,
and please subscribe to the channel
for new content around
how you can be successful
in the first years of your career.
And of course also soft
skills, and hard skills
that might relate to that.
I will release at least
one new video every week,
so su--